okay today i'm going to talk to you
about halogens
so halogens are group 7 of the periodic
table so they're found towards
the right-hand side this means because
they're in group 7 it shows that they
have
seven electrons in the outer shell
so the different halogens so group seven
elements are fluorine chlorine bromine
iodine and astatine
we need to know a few things about these
different elements
so first of all we need to know about
the appearance of chlorine bromine and
iodine
so at room temperature chlorine
appears like a green as a green gas
whereas bromine so if i show bromine
just in a little
uh test tube here so bromine
is a brown liquid now the way
nice easy way to remember that is br
starts for bromine
and b are brown
also it's gives should give off an
orange vapor at room temperature as well
now iodine iodine here
is a dark gray
solid so as you can see
as you go down group seven down your
halogens
the boiling and melting point increases
because this one these ones are gases
bromine is a liquid and these two are
both solid
now iodine also when heated
gives off a purple vapor so those are
the appearances of each of those
different
halogens at room temperature the next
important thing to know about halogens
is they are diatomic
now what that means is they go around in
pairs
so chlorine is cl2
two chlorine atoms covalently bonded
together to form a chlorine molecule
bromine is br2 and
iodine is i2
fluorine would be f2 astatine at2
so as you can see they're diatomic dye
meaning two atoms
so two atoms covalently bonded together
the next thing we need to know about
halogens is their reactivity
because there's a trend as you go down
the group
at the top of the group is the most
reactive one in the form of fluorine
this is the
opposite pattern to that of alkali
metals
it's completely the reversed um
pattern so this for halogens the least
reactive
a right down at the bottom what i'm
going to do now is explain
why fluorine is the most reactive and
why it gets
less reactive the further and further
you go down the table
so i'm going to draw fluorine which has
nine electrons
so there's the first shell one two
three four five six seven eight
nine so as we can see because it's in
group seven
i have one two three four five six seven
electrons
in the outer shell so for halogens
to get a full outer shell they are
looking
to gain one electron
so they need one more electron to
complete their outer shell
so when they're forming an ion they need
to attract
electrons from another
element from another atom so
the reason why fluorine is the most
reactive
is due to the fact it has a very small
atomic radius the atomic radius is the
distance from the center of the atom to
the outer electrons
so as you can see fluorine's atomic
radius
is quite small now the reason why that
makes it reactive is because of this
in the center in the nucleus we have
protons which are positive and they
attract negative electrons from
neighboring atoms
so if i've got a very small atomic
radius
there's going to be more attraction on
these nearby electrons
therefore fluorine is quite reactive
so let's say we've managed to get that
extra electron
so we now have a full outer shell but
i'll just do it in a different color to
show it's come from a different atom
this is what we we have we have fluorine
reacting or gaining an electron
to form f minus
so all halogens form one minus ions
like this so let's just have a quick
look at chlorine
in comparison so chlorine has 17
electrons
so let me just draw this quickly so what
we should be able to see
in a second is the fact that
chlorine has a bigger
atomic radius the distance between the
center of the of the atom
and the outer electrons is much bigger
which means
if the positive protons are attracting
neighboring electrons they're not going
to have
they're not going to be the same degree
of attraction
as with fluorine so as you go down the
group
and the atomic radius gets bigger and
bigger and bigger
there's less and less attraction on
these neighboring or these nearby
electrons
therefore it becomes less and less
reactive
so finally just to show that this time
we have chlorine
gaining an electron so if it was to gain
an electron
we would now have
cl one minus ion and that
is the introduction to halogens thank
you